it's great to welcome back to the
program today bill share who is
contributor to the washington monthly
and real clear politics also host of the
history podcast
when america worked uh bill always great
having you on always great to talk to
you so i i'm trying to understand
different individuals motivations in
either being in favor of or against
the in various iterations of the
infrastructure proposals that we've been
seeing now for for several months let's
kind of start with what's been more in
the news which is maybe joe manchin joe
manchin and and kirsten cinema when i
step back and think about west virginia
you know 47th in healthcare
very close to 50th if not 50th in
education very poor infrastructure would
be a place that would really benefit
from from exactly this it would seem
like hey
his constituents would reward him for
getting them some money
and then the story that's now floating
around is well look at his
uh income from fossil fuel companies
that would be hurt by the climate piece
of this is it is it as simple as a
follow the money type thing well i don't
want to play mind reader uh and i
understand people wanting to connect
dots and everyone's welcome to you know
have their own theories sure uh
but
you know people went into this year
thinking
oh mansion likes the posture but this is
essentially a populist state and so
he'll do the populist thing yeah and now
he's not doing the populist thing some
people are coming with fresh theories i
think you look at mansion's longer
record in politics from his very early
days in west virginia he has always been
a business friendly centrist that has
always been his thing it's not new
and why he's a business really centrist
you're welcome to have your own theories
about that but that just seems to be the
case and
uh you at the end of the day if you want
this bill to pass
you need his vote
however annoying it is to get that vote
it is needed
and i think this is also true for cinema
i think the strategy of
brow beating them publicly
and challenging their political acumen
accusing them of corruption it may all
be true
but it's not getting you their vote
they're not being shamed into moving off
their position so i think a different
tack needs to be taken if they're if
you're going to get to 50 which may be
happening that we're seeing the
conversation starting to materialize now
yeah you and i both i think tweeted
um a disfavor about following kirsten
cinema into the bathroom
um and i as i said you know the what i
said on my show was
maybe you could make the case that the
bathroom is the only place where she
might be confronted by an opposing view
it seems contrary to reality and thus
that as a tactic doesn't seem to me to
be particularly productive but what
what can be done to effectively pressure
a lot of these folks who
you know the the the boaters uh swam up
to the
yacht of joe manchin and uh it wasn't
particularly inspiring the the things
that he said i mean like what actually
works to pressure these people uh from
from an individual voter standpoint yeah
i mean you know different tactics work
on different people there's not a one
size fits all here
but but at minimum
for the last several weeks and months
people have tried
confrontation people have tried getting
to their personal spaces people have
tried haranguing them as being on the
take and not only have they not moved
they seem to have you know dug in their
heels
and even at the precise moment when
progressives thought they were gaining
more leverage
by blocking
the inf the bipartisan infrastructure
build that you know mansion spirit had
cinema essentially wrote it's it's
called cinema portman for pete's sake
yeah uh thinking well if we hold that
hostage that what's prized to them
they'll have to come they have to come
around almost immediately that price tag
on buildback better went down by nearly
50 percent right uh so the tactics just
aren't working and so i i just think the
entire approach of treating them as
effectively adversaries
people who are not progressive who don't
see the world the way we do and need to
be dragged and doing the right thing
that approach isn't working i think you
want to get the temperature down
you want to get into the same room with
them and try to talk to them and figure
out where is the common ground there has
to be i mean if there's no camera
there's no common ground i think there
is some common ground you got to find
where that is and not make it into a
grudge match because the grudge match
isn't working in progressive's favor
yeah i do think that part of what makes
it difficult is it seems as though joe
manchin is very dishonest and what i
mean by that is for a while he was
saying the problem was the price tag as
you mentioned
iterations of this have seen a much
reduced price tag and now he doesn't
like it for different reasons so part of
it is is maybe maybe common ground is
the way to describe that but also moving
goal posts seems to be a real problem
here
well both mansion and cinema can be
i mean manchester can use a lot of word
salad which makes them inscrutable in
certain ways yeah and cinema is very
quiet which makes her inscrutable and
this frustrates the hell out of
progressives
i think it's a negotiating tactic is
working very well for them everyone's
chasing their votes right throwing
things at them to figure out what's
gonna make them happy so they're in the
driver's seat uh i don't think it's fair
to say manchester's move the goal post
because he has been
consistent on a number of things you
look at that piece of paper that he
signed with chuck schumer back in july
now grant this wasn't known to the rest
of us at the time
but he communicated this to his majority
leader all the things that he um wanted
that he was comfortable with and
essentially by omission what he was not
comfortable with uh that's all been
pretty consistent he's been saying for a
long time he doesn't like this clean
energy payment program which is was tend
to be the centerpiece of the climate
section of the bill that's not new uh so
i think he's always had a combination of
price tag concerns
and substantive concerns
uh and
people have tried to you know grind him
down instead of accepting that he holds
a determining vote and so what what are
his concerns de facto become your
concerns you need to resolve those
concerns to get a bill there's many
progressives who every time this happens
say
we got a primary joe manchin and
whenever that happens i tend to think
well i don't know that if a further left
democrat wins the primary they actually
win the general senate election in west
virginia that might lead to replacing a
democrat with a republican
i think we need to be solving this you
you solve 50 50
by taking some existing republican seats
and turning them to democratic seats
what's your general
perspective on this idea of primarying
joe manchin even as as a pressure tactic
to get him to be scared in some way well
he's been primaried and he's unfazed so
i mean west virginia is just too red the
fact that joe mancha is there at all is
a gift for democrats they should be they
would not have a majority without joe
manchin right now it would be mitch
mcconnell said and we wouldn't be
talking about a multi-trillion dollar
bill at all uh so
manchin shrugs that off very gleefully
now cinema is a different story yes uh
uh
cinema seems to have a theory of the
case that she doesn't care either if she
gets primaried that her path of success
is you know is maverickiness
mccain-like um
independence from party leadership and
even though those primary threats are
more pronounced uh and are very
vocalized right now again she's not
budging so again i understand worth
trying it out to see if it might get her
running scared but she's not running
scared uh so i mean maybe by 2024 when
she's up she'll lose that primary i
can't say i i think
she will probably survive a primary it's
very unusual for an incumbent to be
ousted in the primary particular
ideological reasons usually if it
happens it's for a scandal reason uh so
arizona is still pretty purple it's not
hard blue
and they're probably a lot of people in
arizona even who are democrats who say
electability comes first so i would
still put my money on cinema surviving
but it's certainly not a slam dunk uh
but nevertheless she's not being cowed
by that pressure tactic
what is going to or let's we'll work
backwards
does this bill's passage or failure
affect democrats in 2022 is it the type
of thing that voters would actually vote
one way or the other on does joe biden
getting something else big done impact
democrats in 2022 what does matter
looking at the midterms
there's two ways to look at 2022 one is
democrats going to lose no matter what
because it's a midterm president's party
they always lose something the margins
are so narrow that just the tiniest
tiniest bit of something means it's all
over so get what you can while you can
and don't even worry about the politics
right one school of thought it's not
illegitimate um the other is you know
even though it doesn't usually happen it
can happen
it's happened three times in the past
you know i think i think
post-reconstruction
uh that the president's party has gained
a few seats and i think a fourth time
when they just lost like very very
little
enough that democrats could actually
survive this time around uh
and when those things happen
it's almost always because there's some
kind of crisis
and the president's party is seen as
managing that crisis well and so the
usual dynamic of the president's party's
coalition splintering
because of the natural realities of
governing trade-offs compromises
imperfections
unfulfilled aspirations and dreams
things that
deplete some of your base or make some
people the middle peel off while your
opposition is unified against whatever
it is the president's party is doing
that's the reason why the president's
party usually loses
so
if democrats can't pass buildback better
at all or or if it's reduced to such a
nub that it makes people some people
unhappy that makes some people on the
base displeased you know even if it's a
good
general election politics it's good for
the center if that base is unhappy you
know if any if any faction is unhappy
that's bad for the midterms you need
full unity to overcome the historical
trend uh so that's another reason why
it's not good for democrats to be in
this tug of war right now where
someone's going to feel bad regardless
of the outcome you want everyone to feel
good about the outcome even though it's
almost certainly going to be some kind
of compromise what about something like
the afghanistan withdrawal which by the
way i
wasn't remained completely in favor of
and believe it would have been just as
if not more chaotic under donald trump
but that ultimately it's the right
decision when that took place in august
into september there was a lot of talk
of this will torpedo the midterms for
democrats and i really really didn't see
it for two reasons one
that it really was a biden thing and of
course it can affect the midterms we're
talking about that but number two
um it just seems like it's it there's
enough time between then and the
midterms and the relatively short
memories of voters struck me as i don't
think afghanistan is going to play a
factor in the midterms what do you think
i mean i i wrote a piece to that effect
at the washington monthly at the time
and i
with the caveat of some kind of 911
occurring some kind of terrorist attack
on our soil launched from afghanistan
because the terrace outfit was able to
regroup under the current circumstances
that would be you know obviously bad for
people's lives and bad for democrats
politically
outside of that i think we're already
seeing afghanistan fading into the
background of politics
having said that
bayern has not had
a single day
with a good headline
since early august when the afghanistan
withdrawal occurred it means
if it's afghanistan it's kovit
deltavarium it's not kovid it's
something on the border if it's saying
on the border it's the infrastructure
bill being blocked the infrastructure
bill being blocked it's that buildback
better is is in limbo or there's a debt
limit drama you know it's always
something yeah and there hasn't been a
good day
uh and afghanistan was just the first
time when there was an obviously bad day
where people started saying wait a
second maybe these guys don't know what
they're doing maybe they're not perfect
maybe they're not the most competent
operation in the universe uh you can fix
that with some wins but putting some
points on the board uh which is why i
wonder i mean i can't i certainly can't
predict this
and it's not the way it panned out you
know two and a half weeks ago
but we are coming up on another deadline
on october 31st
where
uh nancy pelosi said we need to pass the
bipartisan infrastructure bill
by this date because the highway trust
fund is going to expire now she said the
same thing a month ago
and what happened a month ago was that
progressive said we don't care we're not
gonna give you the votes biden came to
the house and said look these have to be
done at the same time uh and then people
scrambled and passed a highway trust
fund extension for 30 days and
progressives essentially who said this
is this isn't a real deadline because
you can push that off they were proven
correct
however you can only push off that
highway trust fund deadline if
republicans in the senate agree
that's not a that's not a reconciliation
vote that's a regular order vote uh
republicans did that last month because
they said this isn't this doesn't cost
any extra money there's enough money in
the kitty
for
the federal government to pay out
what's needed for road and transit
projects for states and localities but
that may not be the case
two weeks from now so if it's a real
hard deadline i should also say one of
the other negative headline the past few
weeks has been the supply chain issue
yes uh
bayern is saying he's trying to fix that
he knows it's a serious problem and over
the long haul we need to pass the
bipartisan infrastructure bill because
it invests money in ports and freight
rail so he's connecting those two things
right now
do they really want to have the highway
trust fund
you know lapse
so no money is paid out to states and
localities for infrastructure projects
indefinitely
while there is a supply chain crisis
going on right uh
might biden come back to the house in
two weeks and say
look
we're in a jam here people
you know we're not getting anywhere
um build back better we got a supply
chain problem my polls are in the dumps
uh
we're trying to be the infrastructure
party we can't be having infrastructure
projects get throttled over the or i
mean i mean it wouldn't happen in
instant wouldn't be like all of a sudden
everyone drops their their jackhammers
uh but states localities would not know
over time if the money was coming and
that would cause a lot of disruptions
uh and people would vocally complain do
you want those kind of complaints
happening at the state and local level
uh while we've had months and months of
inactivity
from democrats so mike biden come in and
put his thumb on the scale the other way
and say i need you on this vote now i
need you to suck it up and pass this
phone not predicting it i'm saying those
factors are in the mix and one other
factor in the mix i should add virginia
november 2nd is the virginia
gubernatorial election terry mccall the
democratic nominee is saying i'm sick of
these democrats in washington not
getting stuff done
we need this infrastructure bill passed
and some people fear if mcauliffe loses
then everything's going to fall apart
that mansion cinema will be even harder
to get and hard to count out to progress
because they'll say that it's it's your
intransigence that led to this calamity
in virginia uh
programmers might say it's your entrance
it's because you wouldn't do things our
way and just be hard and hard to come to
come to terms so what all that come
together and make democrats suck it up
on the infrastructure bill not
predicting but those are different
factors that were not present a month
ago so wait are you predicting or not
i'm not i'm not sure no yeah
i'm kidding no
not gonna go that far um
it might still conclude yeah yeah yeah
he doesn't want to be a source of party
disunity right no i'm kidding i'm
hesitant to push one faction over the
other yep um by doing a different set of
factors than you did a month ago
without a doubt without a doubt bill
share contributor to the washington
monthly and real clear politics host of
the history podcast when america worked
bill always a pleasure
same here take care